In this example, I have a client side
application that logs in with Google and
is provided a one time use auth code.
The client sends this auth code off to
my server in which in turn communicates
with Google in order to exchange
the code for an authorization token.
The client then sends off this
code to my server, which in turn
communicates with Google in order to
exchange the code for an access token.
If the exchange is successful,
then I create my own token,
which I can send back off to the client
to authenticate with my application.
Let’s start by registering our
application with Google in order to get
a client ID.
We can download our credentials into
a JSON file our code can then point to.
A more detailed walk through is
provided in the instructor notes.
Now in the code,
let's start by refactoring my user model
to take advantage of some of the profile
information I can get from
my OAuth access token.
A user's name, email and profile picture
can be easily obtained with OAuth.
So, I will add these fields now.
I can look up users by their
unique email addresses, so
I will index my database
based on emails as well.
Now that I've used that pi,
I will add a new endpoint called
/oauth/provider that
responds to a post request.
We will first get the one time auth
code if the parameter is set to Google,
then we'll take this auth code and
send it off to Google in exchange for
an access token.
Once I've successfully received
an access token from Google,
I can use it to send an API request to
Google to get my users' information.
I will look up an user based on
the provided email address from
the Google API.
If a user exist,
I will receive that user object.
Otherwise, I will just
make a new user object and
store their information in my database.
Now that I have a user object,
I can generate an off token to allow
that user to access protected endpoints
without having to provide
a user name and password.
And since this course doesn't focus on
creating the client side application
that will send off this
authorization code, I have
added a template that signs into Google
and displays the one time auth code.
View the Instructor Notes to see and
play around with the code
from this video.